I am so pleased to be here tonight to
honor Lynn stall master not only because
of what he's done for our entire
industry but what he has done for me
personally you see Lynn has been very
very good to me and to the entire
bridges family Lynn got me my first gig
in my first movie halls of anger he cast
my brother Bo and his breakthrough movie
directed by Norman Jewison Kayle Kayle
he cast Bo and Hal Ashby's first movie
the landlord cast me in house last movie
with Andy Garcia a mean ways to die al I
really loved working with land and Lynn
way you also put my old man my dad to
work in winters people right so he means
a lot to the bridges family
back in the early 70s Lynne did me an
enormous favor and I don't know if
you're aware of this land but at that
time I was struggling you know trying to
figure out whether or not I wanted to
pursue acting make it my lifetime career
you know this is back in the 70s and the
young kid you know and Lynne offered me
a role in The Iceman Cometh and I
thought oh [ __ ]
this is this is some heavy stuff you
know there's a classic American plane
eugene o'neill directed by john
frankenheimer you got the Frederic March
Lee Marvin Robert Ryan it scared the
hell out of me you know I didn't well I
didn't want to do it you know I tell you
the truth you know I didn't think I
could pull it off I realized what a
wonderful gift it was with a you know
terrific opportunity but I was scared
man
and and then I thought well here I am
I'm trying to figure out you know if I
ought to make you acting you know my
profession if I should be a professional
actor you know for the rest of my life
and I know you know when you're a pro
you're you know you're supposed to do it
when you don't feel like it like I
certainly didn't feel like it but I
thought oh I'm gonna do a little
experiment on myself I do that from time
to time I thought you know I'm just
gonna jump in and do this thing and see
what happens
it'll probably put the final nail in the
acting coffee
you know that'll be a done deal so turns
out that this movie was quite an unusual
experience for man like most movies
where you were Hurst for two weeks than
you shoot for a 1000 or whatever this
one was kind of flipped around we
rehearsed for eight weeks and we shot
for two weeks so it was a lot of hanging
out with these masters you know and
learning that these guys have been
around for so many years still were
anxious about getting it right you know
doing justice to this wonderful material
and in the midst of the anxiety this
theater they had tremendous joy and
loved what they were doing and who they
were getting to do it with and I saw
that this fear that I had well these
guys these guys got it too well and that
it's probably most likely never to go
away and I learned about making friends
with that fear you're using it playing
with it and I also learned that the joy
and the love and the camaraderie and
made it all worthwhile and I figured you
know I can do this I can do this for the
rest of my life so Wow
got it thank you man yeah head me down
that road
Lyne means a lot to me personally and
I'm forever grateful to them but I'm
also here to celebrate what you've given
our industry you know
Casta is one of the most important
elements in making a great movie and
Lynne Stahl master is the master caster
man yeah so thank you land for pointing
the way forward for me and so many
countless others and as well as casting
so many great movies I love you well I
thank you